(band music plays)
- Have you, have y'all met before?
- No, but I have this thing
where I have amnesia
with famous people, so I
- We may well have. We have actually!
- I, we might have met
and if I see you again
- Wait, have y'all met?
- [Eddie] No, I don't really.
But I'm so thrilled to
hear that you have amnesia
cuz I have like a brain like a sieve
and so
- [Emily] Yeah!
- I have exactly the same thing
and it's horrendously offensive
to people I've actually met.
- I know people get
very offended when you don't remember
and it's like, "Oh my God,
there's so many people
in the world.
I'm so sorry."
- It's like I think I have
like this thing where I hold people up.
I met Seth Rogen and I was
like, "So nice to meet you."
And he's like, "Well we met before."
And I was like, "Oh really?"
He's like, "Yeah, remember we met
at the audition for '40 year old Virgin?'"
And I was like, "No. Nope,
I didn't audition for that.
I don't know what you're talking about."
And then it like three weeks
later I was like, "I did.
I did audition for that movie."
I complete-
And it's happened several
times, but I've been savvier
and just been like, "Yes, it
so nice to see you again!"
- Exactly. To see you!
- See you! To see you!
That's, yeah.
- That's very helpful.
Lovely to see you!
- Anyway, but I don't ever get offended
if you don't remember this moment,
I will just not care.
- [Emily] I think I will.
- Yeah. I'll be like, cool.
Me neither.
But your sister Zoe has been here before
and she said that you guys
grew up on sets, right?
On movie sets.
- Yeah. My dad's cameraman
and my mom's an actor
and so we grew up going to visit sets.
So I think the big motivator
for me becoming an actor
was visiting my mom
on set one day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And there were donuts.
- Oh. Craft service.
- So, you know
- [Kelly] Yeah,
for a kid, craft service.
- I go with my plan since then.
- The new show is called "Devil in Ohio."
I did, we were talking about
when we were watching the clip
how we just wanted to
bring the scariest shows
in one episode.
(Eddie and Emily laugh)
Like today.
- Yeah, totally.
- Like it was like we just went real dark
- Creepy.
- for y'all today.
- Yeah. Yours looks so creepy.
- I know. Yours doesn't look not creepy.
It's called "Devil in Ohio."
So what drew you to this role?
- Well, I've always had a fascination
with cults and so this deals with, okay.
(Kelly laughs)
My character's a psychiatrist who,
there's a teenage girl
who escapes from a cult
and she ends up having a great
idea of bringing her home
to her family and having
her move in with her.
And I've always had fascination with cults
but I also was like well, what would make
this psychiatrist decide
to bring home her patient?
So that's I guess where my fascination,
that's why interest
in the show came from.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I love it.
I love the whole, I don't love cults.
I don't, I'm not like into that.
- You don't love cults?
- No, but hey,
but I love that like it's
something that draws you in
because at this point y'all
get to kind of pick what you do
and like what really interests you
and you love in your career.
So it's fun to watch y'all.
- Aww.
- [Kelly] You're so gifted.
- Is fun to watch you.
- So things that got,
well, I don't do scary,
but things that, they did
get creepy on "Bones" though
cuz you were always
around like dead bodies.
Did you ever have to like, like he did,
you know, went to study
as a nurse for a bit
and apparently sucked, but
(guests laugh)
You don't want him around!
But did you ever like
go like I don't know,
to a morgue, like when you did "Bones?"
- Oh yeah, yeah.
We went to the coroner's office.
But I didn't do it right
away when I started.
I did it like a year or
two in, but yeah, that--
The smell!
- [Eddie] Oh my gosh
- I was gonna say
the smell has to be
- Because we were dealing with fake bodies
so we got really used to the fake bodies
and we'd eat our lunch
over them and it's like
you're just used to
like gooing up our hands.
(Kelly laughs)
It was disgusting but we got
completely desensitized to it.
But real bodies smell horrible
especially when they
decompose, apparently.
And so that's the thing
that I stuck with me.
I couldn't get outta my nose.
- Nope.
- [Emily] It was scarring.
- Did it change
like performance then?
- [Emily] No!
- Did you go back and then you go
(Eddie loudly sniffs)
- No, and that's what my choice
at the beginning was like
I don't think I need to do this
cause I think I'm
supposed to be comfortable
with these bodies
- Exactly!
- So I can just use my
imagination to pretend
that I'm comfortable.
- You're an actor!
- And that worked better.
Then I had to like then use
my imagination even more
after going there to think like,
"No, this is okay, this is normal."
Cuz it was.
- That putrid smell is totally fine.
- Yeah, no it doesn't.
I'm used to it.
- Oh no.